[MUSIC PLAYING]
EZRA BRETTLER: It's my pleasure
to introduce Elizabeth Rosner.
She's here today to speak
about her most recent book,
"Survivor Café, The Legacy
of Trauma and the Labyrinth
of Memory."
It grapples with intricate
and possibly unanswerable
questions about how we recognize
and cope with the traumas
we inherit, and
how we can properly
keep alive the personal
stories behind great historical
atrocities even after everyone
who lived through them is gone.
In her focus on
Holocaust survivors,
Rosner uses the lens of
three visits to Germany
with her father, who
was born in Hamburg
and imprisoned in Buchenwald
concentration camp.
The book also investigates the
multi-generational aftermath
of the bombings of
Hiroshima and Nagasaki,
the Cambodian killing fields,
the legacies of slavery,
and other historical atrocities.
I could read from any one of
dozens of endorsements for this
book, but I'll choose one from
the "San Francisco Chronicle,"
which named "Survivor Café" one
of the 100 best books of 2017.
"Survivor Café feels like the
book Rosner was born to write.
Each page is imbued with
urgency, with sincerity,
with heartache, with heart.
Her words, alongside the words
of other survivors of atrocity
and their descendants
across the globe,
can help us build a
more humane world."
Prior to "Survivor Café,"
Elizabeth published three
bestselling novels, the first
of which, "The Speed of Light,"
was internationally acclaimed
and translated into nine
languages.
Its central theme addresses
the effects of the Holocaust
on the descendants of survivors.
A graduate of
Stanford, UC Irvine,
and the University of Queensland
in Australia, Elizabeth
is also my aunt.
I had the opportunity to
accompany her on the third
of the trips to Germany
with my grandfather,
after which she started putting
pen to paper on "Survivor
Café."
Without further ado,
Elizabeth Rosner.
ELIZABETH ROSNER:
Thank you, Ezra.
You forgot to
introduce yourself.
That was Ezra Brettler my
nephew, an employee of Google.
It's great to be here.
Thank you for coming.
Thank you for spending
lunch time with me.
My hope today is that I
will share with you some
of what I think of as the
highlights of what I learned
while writing this book.
It's a blending of the
personal narrative.
As Ezra mentioned, my
role in life, in a way,
as a daughter of two
Holocaust survivors.
Please help yourselves
to books as you come in.
They're for you.
And that then led me to
reaching into a wider
research-based approach
to other lineages that
seem to carry residue
from historical trauma.
And Ezra mentioned
a few of them.
I'll touch on some
of them in my talk.
And I also am going to share
with you some things that we
are learning in the realm
of science about measurable,
evidence-based studies showing
that trauma actually modifies
the expression of DNA, and
that what we have long known
as, anecdotally,
children, grandchildren,
great grandchildren of
people who have endured war
and genocide and other
acts of violence--
that that residue seems to
pervade subsequent generations.
Scientists in the field
of genetics-- a new field,
actually, called
epigenetics is starting
to show that this is not
something we're just imagining,
that it's actually
present and measurable.
Then, I'm going to touch on
some of the impacts of memory
studies and the ways that we
memorialize the past that also
relate to how not just
personal inheritance of trauma,
but the collective
inheritance of trauma
can be addressed in
terms of culture,
in terms of shared
memory, and ultimately
in the hope of healing
and transforming
some of those legacies into
something more hopeful.
And in order, we
hope, not to continue
to repeat a lot of the
atrocities of the past.
So to start with, a
little bit about me.
I grew up in upstate New York.
Both of my parents,
as I mentioned,
were Holocaust survivors.
My mother was in the Vilna
Ghetto, which you may
be familiar with historically.
And then, she survived the War.
In hiding with her parents
in the Polish countryside
as a young teenager.
My father, as you also
heard, was imprisoned
in the Buchenwald concentration
camp at the age of 15,
and the camp was liberated just
after he turned 16 years old.
My parents ended up meeting
as refugees in Sweden,
getting married in Israel,
and then coming to America.
And by the time I was
born, on the very last day
of the '50s, it was as though I
were being born into the other
life that my parents
had created--
their American selves,
their reinvented selves.
And yet, I really did feel
as though something had been
transmitted to me in utero.
And for a long time
people like me,
children of Holocaust
survivors, were
told that we were being
hysterical or too sensitive
about feeling as though
our emotional landscape,
our psychological landscape,
was so impacted by something
that didn't happen to us.
But in fact, as I
mentioned, we are
starting to recognize that
this is a real phenomenon.
So I became a writer
partly because I kept
on wanting to ask questions.
You've probably heard that
writers are encouraged
to write what they know.
Well, in my case, I wanted to
write what I wanted to know.
So writing for me has always
been an act of curiosity
and inquiry and investigation.
And this book, even
though it comes
after three novels and a
poetry collection, in many ways
really does feel
like the book that
contains all of
the questions I've
been asking all of my life.
What is it that I carry that
happened before I was born?
How does that not
differentiate me from others,
but actually make me feel
even more connected to others?
When I was growing
up, I often felt
like I was markedly
different from my peers.
A lot of the Americans
in my hometown
had been there for generations.
I was a first-generation
American,
as was my older sister
and my younger brother,
so we had something in
common with each other.
And our small kind of tribe, my
parents' friends a lot of them
were also survivors of
the Holocaust in Europe.
But in the larger
sense, I didn't feel
like I was much like my peers.
And so, over time, I
started to recognize
that the more I looked into
what I felt made me so unusual--
that I felt so
sensitive to, let's say,
anxieties or preparing
for catastrophe,
or there were some
friends of mine
I know whose parents
also survived going
into exile from the Holocaust.
They always kept a suitcase
packed just in case.
Things like that we considered
normal, most of our friends
thought that was a little
bizarre, a little paranoid
maybe, or a little
over-reactive, oversensitive.
And yet, over time, I
became more and more clear
that, in fact, subsequent
generations of Japanese
who survived Hiroshima
and Nagasaki actually
have some similar behavior
patterns and thought patterns.
So do the descendants of
African-American slaves
in the United States.
So do refugees from
Cambodia who survived
the killing fields in Cambodia.
And unfortunately,
the list does go on.
It's a big list.
And in the book, I don't
cover every atrocity
because, in fact, the
more research I did,
the more I realized that
even in the news as I
was writing the book new
atrocities were taking place.
So I don't, for
example, include what's
happening to the
Rohingya in Myanmar
even though that
is in this moment
a genocide unfolding
before our eyes.
So the conversation
is a big one,
and what I'm trying
to do is allow you
some intimate access
to a personal story
and then see how you might
find your own connection
to that story.
Even if you don't
necessarily recognize
any of the places
I've referred to,
your own family
lineage is probably
inscribed with something that
was then passed through you
intergenerationally.
I'm going to read you a passage
from one of the psychiatrists
that I cite in my
book who specializes
in inherited trauma.
She works with
families whose children
seem to be exhibiting
signs of PTSD
even when the
children themselves
have not been traumatized.
And this is the great
mystery that we've
been trying to understand.
How is it that you
can look at somebody
who grew up seemingly in a safe
and protected environment still
be displaying signs of PTSD?
So I'm going to read you
her definition of how
this PTSD shows up.
"Unresolved trauma takes
two different forms.
The first is dissociation,
where the trauma is blocked.
There are no words.
Not only pushed away, but
insecurely pushed away."
And just to explain
about that a little bit.
So this kind of numbing
effect, this way
of sort of not being present in
the moment, is for some people
a form of PTSD.
An inability to
manage their emotions
is so overwhelming that
they just shut down
completely emotionally.
"The second way,
the opposite way,
is where the trauma is
uncontainable, overflowing.
Interactions are
overflowing with emotion.
The person mixes
past and present.
The trauma intrudes in
places it doesn't belong."
And that's the sentence I
really want to focus on.
"The trauma intrudes on
places it doesn't belong."
It's sometimes defined as
people's inability to feel safe
in a safe environment.
So you may know someone
or have witnessed someone
or experienced it
yourself sitting
in a perfectly quiet place--
out in nature, perhaps--
where everything
seems to be completely
tranquil and unthreatening.
And yet, your heart is racing,
your pulse is going mad.
You might break out in a sweat.
These are signs that,
internally, you're
experiencing not what the
present moment is offering up,
but some associative
experience that makes you
feel as though you're
not in the present.
You're actually in some
other past maybe experiencing
things that were handed
to you by parents
or even grandparents.
So I'm going to try to define
epigenetics for you briefly
and to say, first of all,
that I'm not a scientist.
So sometimes, people object
to the concept of epigenetics
as though they want
to take issue with it.
And you're welcome to look it
up and do your own research.
I'm not the person who
has done the research.
I'm citing the research.
So it began with mice.
Emory University in Atlanta,
a group of geneticists
took some pre-adolescent
mice and exposed them
to the scent of
cherry blossom, which
is a chemical compound,
and an electroshock.
So the mice quickly learned
to associate that scent
with fear, panic, and pain.
So even when the shock
was no longer present,
they would get
extremely agitated.
When these mice
produced offspring--
now, remember, they
were pre-adolescent,
so none of these
mice was pregnant,
there were no baby
mice in utero--
three and four
generations of mice
later, when those
mice were exposed
to cherry blossom for the
first time, they panicked.
They acted as if they already
knew the associative pain
that they might receive.
They had never witnessed
their ancestry mice
being exposed to the
scent or the shock.
So these researchers
concluded that something
had shifted in the DNA that
was being passed to them.
Now, the DNA itself wasn't
necessarily being modified.
It was epigenetically,
meaning something
on top of the DNA in the
gene was being modified.
And they call that the
expression of the gene.
Sometimes, cortisol levels,
which are associated with
stress--
hormone that we produce to
help us respond to stress--
was either suppressed
or exaggerated.
At the same time that
those studies with mice
were going on, there
were researchers
in Israel looking at
Holocaust survivor families
and noticing something similar.
That grandchildren,
great grandchildren
of Holocaust survivors
were coming in for therapy
with symptoms of PTSD for
trauma that they themselves
had not lived through.
And so they started to connect
the dots between these studies.
The studies are small.
Humans don't reproduce
as quickly as mice.
So we don't know
yet how residual,
how long lasting
these effects are,
but notable enough for people
to raise questions and encourage
more studies to be
done to look into this.
So it turns out that, for
example, Cambodian refugees
living in the United
States are coming
into therapeutic contexts
with about a 95% rate of PTSD
in the community.
Off-the-charts high.
In Cambodia, it's estimated
that somewhere between one
out of four and one out
of every three Cambodians
was murdered by the Khmer Rouge.
Monumental portions of the
population were impacted--
not only by the losses,
but by the fear associated
with those losses, the
reign of terror that
lasted for the years the
Khmer Rouge were in power.
And you can sort of
do the math yourself.
These numbers need
to be looked at.
So what's happening in the
United States right now,
I think, is pretty
strong evidence
that we have unresolved
trauma throughout the country.
We have unresolved legacies of
racism, slavery, Jim Crow laws,
you name it-- lynching.
The aftermath of
lynching in a community
has never fully been addressed.
And we are seeing what
it looks like when
we don't address
trauma, when we don't
address the residue of trauma.
In Japan, they also have
similar investigations
into these lineages of
the survivors of Hiroshima
and Nagasaki who, for
example, were often completely
silent on the subject.
Their radiation
exposure was so severe
that they feared that, if
their children were known
to be the offspring of
people who had been exposed
to radiation, no one would want
to marry them because of fear
of birth defects.
So there was a long
history of silence
about the effects of those
bombs and the fallout--
the literal fallout.
We use fallout now as a
metaphor, but it was literal.
It still is literal.
So a lot of what I'm
talking about in my book
is actually this interconnection
between literal residue,
literal lasting
radioactivity in the body,
and what that means
metaphorically--
that we do carry
the effects of what
happened to our ancestors
and our cultural companions,
our compatriots.
So what that leads me,
then, to consider is,
how do we do this
memory together?
How do we remember not just
what happened in my family,
for example?
My nephew introduced this
story of three different trips
I took to Germany with
my father, one in 1983,
one in 1995 and
the third in 2015.
So in 1983, I was in my 20s,
my father was in his 50s,
and Germany was still divided.
So when we went
first to Hamburg then
to Berlin to pass through
Checkpoint Charlie
to get permission to
enter into East Germany
and visit the site of the
camp, what we were facing
was a culture, a country,
that was choosing to remember
the past in a particular way.
Their historical version of what
had happened in World War II
focused primarily on the
victory for them of communism
over fascism.
When we tried to visit the
site of the concentration camp,
we were directed away
from the camp itself
to a monument located
a couple of kilometers
away that had victorious
communist statues celebrating
their victory over the fascists.
Jews were not part
of the conversation.
So my father and I did find our
way to the site of the camp.
There was nobody there.
We were the only
two people there.
It was this vast, barren field
of gravel still surrounded
by barbed wire and guard
towers, but nobody inside them.
So that was my first
experience of feeling
the presence of those ghosts.
And the fact that
I could share this
with my father in such a way
that literally, literally
we both heard in
the wind the sound
of people screaming
at the same time.
And for me, that was a
palpable sense in my body
that something my
father had lived through
was really passing into my body.
And at the end of
that trip, he said,
I want to come back with
the rest of the family.
I was becoming a
writer, and, of course,
my material seemed so obvious.
My family's story
was my material.
So flash forward 12
years later to 1995.
And now, my siblings and
I, my mother, and my father
are all going to the
reunified Germany together.
And Buchenwald is now the
center of a commemoration site.
It was being celebrated
with a feast, a banquet,
on the site of the
concentration camp--
a completely surreal event
that I write about in the book.
I felt like Fellini
had filmed this.
It was just bizarre,
a giant tent
on the site of this place
where so many people were
starved and worked to
death and murdered.
And right in the
middle of the meal,
one of my father's
front teeth fell out.
And suddenly, he
looked-- have you ever
seen someone with a missing
tooth, this hole suddenly
appearing in his
smile and his face.
And I was remembering,
in that experience,
that when we had
been there in 1983
together he passed a kidney
stone while we were there.
So you can see how the
body has its own way
of remembering trauma and
re-experiencing, revisiting
trauma.
So now, the context was
Germany was reunified.
They were trying to reorganize
their memory, literally,
of how they were
remembering what had
happened during World War II.
20 years later, 2015, my
nephew and I and my Father
are all in the same place.
Now, we're three
generations together.
And we are being echoed and
met by three generations
of Germans, especially
the grandchildren,
who call themselves like
the Jewish compartment
generation of survivors,
third generation,
they call themselves 3G.
That's how I found out I was 2G
because my 3G nephew explained
to me that I was now a member
of this second generation.
The grandchildren
of the survivors
and the grandchildren
of the Nazis
were now taking
it upon themselves
to remember together
what had happened.
So there was this
remarkable bridge
across the great
divide of history,
to say it's our obligation
to remember this together
and to look at our counterparts
as fellow travelers
through this journey of
what part of the past
is still impacting us
now in the present.
In Japan, something
similar is happening.
The first, second, and
third-generation survivors
of Hiroshima and
Nagasaki are also
asking themselves, how do
we keep this memory alive?
And I mentioned a
little while ago
that this memory is both
personal and collective.
Even if you're not personally
related to the survivors,
how do more we all carry
this in a shared way?
And in Japan, there's
a remarkable role
being taken on by people who
call themselves dinshosha,
which is translated
as the designated
transmitter of memory.
And the dinshosha are
memorizing the stories
of the survivors of
Hiroshima and Nagasaki
so that they can
tell the story when
the firsthand experience is
no longer available in person.
They are literally choosing
to embody the story
and humanize it, keep it
individual and meaningful
in that way.
So what are some other
parallels for that?
Well, in South
Africa, you probably
know, after apartheid
ended, Mandela and others
created something called
the Truth and Reconciliation
Commission, where they
chose to coordinate
the remembering of the past--
not in a legal,
punishing format,
but in a way of creating
dialogue and conversation,
allowing the
victims of apartheid
to speak to the
perpetrators and be heard,
simply have their stories
be told as the truth.
Because, one of the first things
that goes in war and atrocity
and genocide is truth itself.
I'm afraid we're witnessing
a lot of this right
now in our culture, when
facts are becoming distorted
and the truth seems blurry
at the edges, blurry at best.
So, in Rwanda,
where there was also
a horrific genocide
in the late 1990s,
when 800,000 Tutsis were
murdered by their Hutu
neighbors with machetes
in four months--
800,000 people murdered in
a period of four months--
now, the Rwandan
government is trying
to help the remaining Hutus
and the remaining Tutsis work
together to rebuild the
country as neighbors.
They were neighbors
before the genocide.
They are neighbors again.
How does this work?
How can you bring victims
and perpetrators together
in a way that isn't
retraumatizing?
Well, it's complicated.
When I was revising
"Survivor Café,"
every time I wrote about
something like this,
I would go back over the
book again and again.
My last time to
reread it, I looked
for the word complicated.
I did a word search
for complicated.
It showed up 49 times.
I had to go back through
and really consider
the nuances of that word, but
everything I was talking about
was, indeed, complicated.
The complication of how many
generations past slavery
in America are we,
and yet we are still
bearing witness to
the unresolved trauma
that it left behind.
Bryan Stevenson, who is an
African-American lawyer who
used to be with the
Southern Poverty Law Center
and started something called
the Equal Justice Initiative,
has been determined to create
monuments in every location
where a lynching took place.
In Europe, something similar
had been done, is being done.
An artist put down what he
called Stolpersteine, stumbling
stones, replacing
individual cobblestones
with gilded-over stones stamped
with the name of a person who
was murdered.
And they say, here lived this
person's name, this person's
birthdate, and died in
Auschwitz, Treblinka,
Ravensbruck, Majdanek--
the names of camps, the names
of maybe unknown locations.
So Bryan Stevenson
said the power
of standing on a spot where
you know an atrocity took
place has to be replicated
in the United States
where these lynching sites were.
Thousands of people witnessed
lynchings in America.
It wasn't just the
horrific violence
done to the individual.
There was an act of violence
committed in full view of often
the entire town.
So how do we remember that in
a way that honors the victim
and tells the truth
about what happened?
So plaques are being placed in
locations where lynchings took
place, and a big
museum in Montgomery
is being built with soil
from each of those places
to be held in jars
and vessels to say,
we are all connected by
this earth that we stand on.
So even though I might
be tempted to say,
my ancestors weren't
slave owners,
I'm a first-generation
American, I
don't have to take
responsibility
for the residue of
this trauma, simply
by being an American
standing on American soil,
I do have to take
responsibility for what
happened in this
country and that I'm
the beneficiary
of a lot of things
that we all benefited
from during slavery
and all of the inhuman
violence committed
against post-slavery Americans.
So how do we remember well?
How do we work carefully
to preserve this memory?
And to keep it
personal, as I said,
and also to keep it alive once
the witnesses and the people
who enacted those crimes or
were the victims of those crimes
are no longer here to remind
us of the human experience?
So I don't know how
many of you have ever
been to Washington, DC,
the US Holocaust Museum
in Washington DC, and also
the very recently completed
African-American Museum
of History and Culture.
Anybody?
Have you been?
They are both astonishingly
important institutions.
I really recommend
that you visit them.
And they each tell
a story, a narrative
that is meant to
engage you physically
in the process of memory.
So at the Holocaust Museum,
when you enter the museum,
you're conducted to an elevator,
taken up to the top floor.
And when you step
out of the elevator,
the first thing you
see is a photograph
of American soldiers looking
down at a pile of corpses
that they encountered when they
arrived at a concentration camp
in Europe in April of 1945.
Now, what I realized when
I went to that Museum
and saw that image was that
this is the American version
of that story.
My version growing
up, as I told you,
before I even knew what I knew,
I knew that something horrible
had happened to my
parents in Europe
that involved images and
situations that I was now
seeing.
Americans encountered and
thought, oh, now we understand.
But, of course,
there's a whole story
that has to be
revisited in order
to understand what they were
seeing for the first time.
So then, you work your way
through the Museum finding out
everything that took place
that led to that moment,
but it's still an American
frame around a story.
I think that's really
important to understand--
that museums, as fact
based as they can be,
are framing a narrative.
So what's happening
now in the South,
where they're
talking about what do
we do with Confederate
statues, is
a question about who gets
to frame the narrative.
Do we keep the statues
there because they
signify a Civil War that really
did take place in America?
Well, don't we need
context around them?
Don't we need to know that
they were defending something
that we now consider to
be completely abhorrent?
It wasn't just, oh, the
North won and the South lost.
It was that they were
diametrically opposed
ideologies, one of which
believed that you were entitled
to own other people.
That was a wrong ideology.
So for us to say,
well, there were
just two different
ideologies is, I think,
an affront to the victims.
Right
So now, there's this debate
about what kind of structure
or museum can we put
these Confederate statues
inside of so a fuller
story gets told about who
they were, what they meant.
And they were on the wrong
side of history, basically.
So the African-American
Museum of History and Culture,
interestingly to me,
takes the other approach
from this Holocaust Museum
top-down descent into the past.
The African-American
museum starts
with the past underground.
You start down below
in this Museum,
and you read and enter into the
centuries of the slave trade--
a lot of which was based
on sugar, so I'll let you
think about that for a moment.
Sugar, the demon.
So you climb through this
lower portion of the story,
and you work your way
up through slavery
in America, the Civil War,
followed by Jim Crow, the Civil
Rights Movement.
And finally, at the
very top of the museum,
in this incredible
celebratory way,
you get to experience the
beautiful and significant
contributions of
African-Americans to American
culture--
music, dance, theater, language,
fashion, everything, language,
hip hop, the vernacular
expressed through architecture
and movement--
all of which shows that the
bones that lie underground
have still somehow
managed to produce
this incredible resilience
and beauty and transformation.
So weirdly, I decided to
start that Museum at the top.
I think I saw all the
crowds going down,
and I wanted to be different.
And I started at the top.
And I'll tell you, it was
hard to leave that floor.
It was so full of wonder and joy
and celebration and innovation
and creativity.
But then, I
remembered that I had
to see what was
buried under that.
I had to see what was in the
soil that gave birth to that.
And it reminded me that
we don't just inherit
the trauma of our ancestors.
We inherit the resiliency
of our ancestors.
We inherit the perseverance
of our ancestors
and the will to
go on and the will
to create a new life
in a new place--
like my parents did, like
maybe many of your parents
or grandparents did.
So I want to leave you
with a couple of questions
about consciousness with
language, consciousness
with how we use our words.
So I don't know how many of
you react to language the way
I do, but, for
example, when I hear
the words ethnic cleansing,
the phrase ethnic cleansing--
which we heard during the
eruptions in Bosnia when
Yugoslavia was falling apart
and the Serbs were trying
to ethnically cleanse
the Christians out
of the Serbian-held
territories--
there was a big outcry
about what a euphemism
that phrase was.
That ethnic cleansing was
essentially a cover up
for genocide and mass murder.
Do you remember?
It's come back into
our vocabulary again.
"The New York
Times" is referring
to what's happening in
Myanmar as ethnic cleansing.
And sometimes, they put
quotation marks around it,
and sometimes they don't.
And to me, this seemingly
normalized version
of that phrase is
saying something
about how we have
accepted propaganda terms
into our vocabulary as if
they are descriptive rather
than propaganda.
So chain migration
is another phrase.
There is debate about the use
of the phrase chain migration.
If you're not aware
of it, look into it.
The idea that people who are
legally immigrated into America
and want to bring family and
relatives, now that phrase
chain migration is being used
again in a propagandist way
to hear these echoes
of, I hear slavery, I
hear chains of poverty, of
lower class relationships,
of illegal activity.
All of these invocations
that this language produces,
we need to question.
So instead of using these
phrases automatically,
I recommend that we use the
phrase family unification
or reunification instead
of chain migration.
It's actually more accurate.
It's equally descriptive.
It's more accurately descriptive
than chain migration.
Instead of ethnic
cleansing, genocide
is the more appropriate term.
Mass murder is the
more appropriate term.
Why do these words matter?
Because they impact our ways
of thinking about the world.
They impact how we
see one another,
the assumptions we make.
Do you remember
when the photograph
of the drowned
Syrian child appeared
everywhere, one of the
victims of a drowning
off the coast of Greece?
There are millions of refugees
in flight for their lives.
That one photograph
of a drowned child
was a way of saying
to people, don't
forget this is happening
to one person at a time.
When you call people
immigrants, it's
different than when
you call them refugees.
The emotional content is really
different in those two terms.
Don't you feel your heart more
likely to open toward a refugee
than toward an immigrant who,
the implication being, oh, they
just come are coming
here because they
want better opportunities?
They?
We should say we, are coming
here for better opportunities.
But refugee means,
oh, someone who
has no choice, someone who is
in flight for his or her life
or the life of their
extended family.
So language matters because it
impacts how we think and feel
about human lives, about
human lack of choice,
about humans in exile, about
humans who are suffering.
So, for me, all of
this research was
a way of saying to
myself, what I grew up
with didn't just
teach me that I was
carrying a particular burden.
It taught me that I
have a responsibility
to be empathetic toward
those who suffer, too--
whether I know their
full story or not,
whether I know how many
generations back the suffering
goes on or not.
But that each
individual actually
has some kind of legacy
of sorrow, of loss,
of harm, of pain.
And it may be vast.
It may be on the scale
of Cambodia, one out
of three or four people in
the entire country murdered
by the Khmer Rouge.
It might be on a
smaller scale, but it
doesn't matter the scale.
What matters is the personal
level of identification
and that willingness to say we
are connected by what we carry,
and we can recognize that in one
another through our language,
through our storytelling,
through our collective forms
of memory in museums
or institutions
or installations like a
stone placed on a sidewalk
saying this was a person who
lived here and was murdered.
So, if I may, before I open
it up to your questions--
which I really welcome and
invite, questions or comments--
I want to leave
you with an image.
And it's a Japanese term
and a Japanese art form
that I think is, again, a
beautiful metaphor for all
that I've been
talking about today.
Kintsugi is sometimes
translated as golden repair,
but I've recently
seen it translated
as the art of embracing damage,
or the art of precious cars--
the art of embracing damage,
the art of precious scars.
So imagine a precious
bowl, a piece of pottery
that was handed down to
you, or something you made,
or something you paid a lot
of money for, and it shatters.
Cry, throw it away.
You have a lot of choices.
Replace it with a
new perfect one.
Kintsugi says you fill
in the cracks with gold.
You repair it in such a way
as to enhance and identify
more fully where the bowl
has been broken and how,
in healing it, in putting
the pieces back together,
you see all of its history.
You see the damage it
went through and is still
not just whole but, in
fact, more beautiful than it
was before.
So the damage that
we carry doesn't
have to be looked at as loss or
pain that will never go away,
that we'll never heal from.
But neither does it that we're
trying to make it go away
and erase it so that we never
have to look at it again.
The truth is we have ongoing
damage every day, all the time,
to our bodies, our psyches, our
culture, our truth, our story.
So this image for me is so, so
resonant of an option we have--
to hold our damage
delicately, lovingly,
and to let it be seen.
To say I am not
only that the pain
and the loss that
have happened to me,
but I am also filled
with something even more
precious and more
beautiful, which
is the restoration of self.
And ultimately, I hope
an image like this
is an indication of what we're
capable of as human beings--
that we can create
a wholeness that
doesn't keep repeating the
separations and the murders
and the hatreds, but
rebuilds a culture that
is based on something collective
and connected and healing,
I hope.
So thank you for
listening to me.
I really hope that you'll
make sure to take a book
to take with you to
read and consider,
but I would love to know if you
have any questions right now
or comments.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you not
believe, when we pass away,
our body returns to dust,
but the spirit persists?
All the memories, all the
experiences actually persist.
Now, let me use a
technical term like cloud.
Imagine all those memories
stay in the cloud.
And if a younger generation,
a different generation
can access that piece of
information using a token,
like a password
from the cloud, that
could explain that
different generations may
be able to the same
traumatic experience,
and somehow you just persist
throughout generations.
What do you think about that?
ELIZABETH ROSNER: I love it.
What I think about
it is that I love it.
I think it's a
brilliant interweaving
of our technological
understanding of how
data is saved and this human
data, this data of memory.
My father actually, who
thankfully is still alive--
he's going to be 89 in April--
has often said to me,
I wish there was a way
that all of my
knowledge that I've
gained over all of these
years of living and learning
could be stored
somewhere and saved
so that it can be passed on.
What a shame that
it can't be saved.
And so he's envisioning
this giant brain download.
But as you say,
it's Spirit, too.
It's not just what we hold
in our minds and our bodies.
There's something that we
don't quite know what it is
or how it operates.
Jung talked about this, too.
Jung envisioned
your cloud, as well,
when he talked about the
collective unconscious,
and that what we
carry ancestrally
shows up in our
dreams sometimes.
I know a woman whose mother was
also in a concentration camp,
and this woman has
dreams that, when
she tells her mother about them,
her mother says, you dreamed
something that happened to me.
How is that possible, that a
dream could be transmitted?
Well, this is the
kind of thing that I
think you've just described.
That it's all being
stored somewhere.
And that at birth, that token
that you just mentioned,
our birth is our pass
key to access that.
Brilliantly said.
Thank you for sharing that.
Any other questions or comments?
Please.
Sorry.
That microphone is so far away.
AUDIENCE: I notice that most
of the examples you gave
were like large-scale things
like the Holocaust or slavery.
I'm wondering if you think the
same ideas you've presented
apply to smaller things like
individual trauma or maybe
what I had in mind, like mass
shootings, or things like that?
ELIZABETH ROSNER: Absolutely.
Thank you for that question.
I think that I do in the
book, talk about 9/11,
which, of course, as
a country we thought
of as happening to all of us.
But we know that,
in actual fact,
it happened to two buildings in
New York City and the Pentagon.
We know that, in
theory anyway, it was
a limited number of victims.
But what we recognize is that
the entire country does still
feel the reverberations
of that event.
So I don't know if that's
an example of what you're
talking about, but I also think
the MeToo movement right now
is evidence of
something very similar.
Women and young
girls who have all
experienced some form of sexual
assault, sexual violence,
sexual abuse, one by
one, individual stories
begin to emerge as a
wave of experience that
lasted not just for generations
but millennia in a way.
So the connection,
I think, between
the individual experience
and the bigger story
is present whenever there's
an individual trauma.
I don't go into this in the
book-- again, like I said,
I had to choose
what I included--
but I know, for example,
in the gay community,
especially in the
community of people
who were exposed to AIDS
in the '80s and '90s,
that there's actually a
syndrome that is referred
to as AIDS survivor syndrome.
That people who lived and
had all of their friends
die all around them but didn't
die for whatever reason--
we're still trying
to study why did
very few people who
were HIV-positive not
succumb to AIDS.
They have this
experience of, am I
fortunate or am I
hugely unfortunate
that I've lost everyone I loved,
that I witnessed everyone's
death and dying all around me?
So that's another example.
Also, just individual
experiences
of a suicide in the family.
That can feel certainly like
an ongoing trauma in a family.
And then, an individual
might look back
at multi-generational
patterns in the family
and see, oh, each
generation had a suicide.
What does that mean?
We're just starting
to understand this.
There's another term
you might come across
in addition to epigenetics.
It's an acronym, ACEs,
Adverse Childhood Experiences.
And pediatricians
and educators are
starting to come up with a tool
for measuring when they meet
a young child and the child
is acting out behaviorally
in school or not
wanting to go to school
or there are crazy things
going on with the kid,
they'll ask the kid how
many of these things--
or they're asking an
adult related to the kid--
is there poverty in
the home, is there
someone incarcerated
in the family,
is there mental
illness in the family,
is there homelessness
in the family.
And they calibrate and quantify
these adverse childhood
experiences and say a
score of such and such
is likely to lead to
mental illness, health
problems, early death.
So we're trying to intervene
at younger and younger ages
now to recognize how even
individual traumas reverberate
throughout a culture
and a system.
Does that answer your question?
Thank you.
Other questions?
A comment is more
than welcome, too.
Please.
AUDIENCE: So when I see
[INAUDIBLE] what I actually
see is that in the 1500s,
Japan invaded Korea,
and they took thousands
of [INAUDIBLE] prisoner.
Before that, most of the
peasants [INAUDIBLE] were good.
And so, then, when I
actually see the [INAUDIBLE]
I see the history of where
that actually came from.
So we only see that as a
sign of reconciliation,
but that itself actually has
hidden that history behind it.
And when you mentioned Bosnia,
the Serbs, when it was going,
there was a newspaper article
I read a long time ago,
in Serbia there is
actually a museum where
one of the things that was
displayed in the museum
is something that looks
like a tuning fork--
tuning for, as in U-shaped.
Serbian people actually
had that tuning fork
because before the
Bosniaks were actually
gouging the eyes of the
Serbs using the fork.
And so, when we actually
see history of genocide,
it actually goes deeper.
It's not just against
Serbs or Bosnians.
There's a deep history of a
vicious cycle that went on.
And so we don't get to see
a lot of reconciliation
throughout the history.
My recollection of the only
history of reconciliation
was when I saw the recording
of Nelson Mandela being
interviewed after
his prison release.
One of the first things
they said was, I forgive.
And that literally made
me jump out of a chair
because that's something
totally unexpected,
but that actually gave hope
to the future of South Africa.
That black people coming
into power in South Africa
wasn't going to be that bad
because here's the fighter who
resisted apartheid
for such a long time
and put under arrest
and prison life
coming out and saying
that he actually
forgave those perpetrators and
he's actually willing to work
with them for a better future.
Unfortunately, those are very
rare occurrences in history.
And now, what I'm seeing is
that I hear news about Syria
where people are dying.
Civilians are dying.
And I hear about Yemen, where
there's a proxy war going on
between Saudi Arabia and Iran.
And even in the States,
I like to travel,
but probably the last
place I want to travel
is probably Alabama where
people were actually
rooting for Roy Moore in
this present day and age.
So I have three kids.
I want to leave a better
future for my kids.
But at the same time,
I wonder, is the world
getting any better?
Has history taught
us any lessons?
Where do we end
this vicious cycle?
How can a country, when
seemingly I'm in the minority
and my voice is drowned
out, how do I reconcile it?
And I was actually
coming to the TED Talk
to hear a little bit of maybe--
I was looking for
some sort of a clue
as to how you were able
to find the reconciliation
between the Germans
and the Nazis.
ELIZABETH ROSNER: I don't
mean to cut you off.
We're running out of time.
I want to say you
do have a voice.
Your voice is really powerful
in what you've just been saying.
And I do think that Mandela
is a beautiful example,
a rare example.
Forgiveness is not
necessarily something that
can be flipped like a switch.
It's incredibly rare that
somebody can even privately
make a statement like that.
But Germany is an
amazing exemplar
right now, a model country
in taking responsibility
for their history and preserving
it even when it shows them
in their worst light.
And that gives me hope, that
Germans aren't saying bygones,
let it be considered
history and we are no longer
obligated to remember.
There was a time when
Germans said that,
and there are definitely
still Germans who say that.
So I can't speak for every
German who is committed
to this honest pathway.
But reconciliation is a
goal, and it's very difficult
to achieve.
And forgiveness,
I don't even know
if that is a goal so much
as a form of justice.
There's retribution,
and there's restoration.
So retribution is
more where people
want to take revenge and
see punishment meted out.
And restorative justice
is more a way of,
saying let's at least
have the truth be told.
And that's where you begin.
And if forgiveness eventually
arises as a result,
that's good, but
not necessary maybe.
So the complications in Asia,
the complications in Africa,
there's a whole colonial
legacy underneath all of that.
The Tutsis were raised up
by the European colonials,
and the Hutus were pushed down.
So the Hutus have this long
history of feeling dehumanized,
disenfranchised.
So yes, they were acting out
of an old, old rage, too.
And there were massacres by
Tutsis of Hutus, apparently.
I'm learning now.
The Armenian Genocide
is a long story,
and Armenian Genocide is
a phrase you can't even
say aloud in Turkey.
It's illegal to say in Turkey.
That doesn't mean
it didn't happen.
Now, Poland is trying to
criminalize references
to the Polish participation
in the Holocaust.
So I think, to end on a
note that's complicated,
the worst of us
is getting worse,
and I hope that the best
of us is getting better.
Thank you for your comment.
Thank you all so
much for being here.
I'm going to stick around for
a while if you want to talk.
Is our time up?
We can keep going?
No?
We ended a long time ago.
Haha.
OK.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Ezra.
Thanks Google.
Thank you all.